Another new feature in Unreal Engine 5 is mass entity.
This is a framework for data oriented calculations.
A mass entity's primary data structure is the fragment.
A fragment is a data only element
and it represents an atomic piece of data
that can be used in calculations.
Examples of fragments are things
such as transforms and velocity.
It's important to note that fragments cannot be created
in blueprint at present.
Fragments can be grouped into collections
and these collections can then be associated
with an ID.
This collection of fragments is then what we call an entity.
The idea associated with the entity
can be used for quick lookups
and creating an entity is similar to class instance
in object orientated programming.
However, instead of directly declaring a class
and its functionality,
entities are built up by fragment composition.
An example of an entity,
we can take two fragments such as transform and velocity.
These two fragments now form our entity
which would then give a unique ID.
Again, it's important to note
that entities are data only elements
so they have no internal logic within them.
Moving one step further, we have archetypes.
Archetypes are a collection of entities
of an identical composition.
Archetypes are composed of different types of fragments
in a specific configuration.
Taking our previous example of an entity
made up of a transform and a velocity,
we can build a collection of entities
that hold the same configuration,
giving us our archetype.
So let's take a look at a visualization
of an archetype.
We can see that we have an archetype
that holds an entity made up of transforms
and velocities as per our example.
Now let's have a look at how that archetype
is organized internally.
Entities of an archetype are organized in memory chunks.
Arranging data in chunks like this
ensures best performance when retrieving fragments
associated with entities
of the same archetype from memory.
Processes are stateless classes
that supply the processing logic for fragments.
It makes use of entity queries
to specify which types of fragments
they need to perform their operations on.
A good example of a processor
is the mass apply movement processor,
which is already present in the latest version
of Unreal Engine 5.
Entity queries provide batches of fragments
to the processes with their regard
to individual entity identifiers.
As we can see here,
we have an entity query that will return our processor
to arrays of transforms and velocities,
the exact makeup of our example entity.
A tag is a trivial fragment that contains no data.
The existence or absence of a tag
is used as data in its own right.
Tags are part of the entity's composition.
A chunk fragment is a fragment
associated with a chunk instead of an entity.
Chunk fragments are used to store per chunk data,
which are used in managerial processing
like calculating levels of detail.
They're also used as part of the entity composition
system much like tags.
Moving on to the last major addition
to Unreal Engine 5's AI suite of tools,
we have the zone graph.
The zone graph was envisioned
to be a lightweight navigation system
that allowed for pathfinding
even with non-stream portions of the world,
and for general control of direction and navigation.
The zone graph uses metadata
to represent specific navigation flows
such as traffic lanes, sidewalks, or wood trails.
This metadata is represented
as a point-to-point corridor structure
connected by segments.
In the next few slides,
we're gonna take a look how we can define
our own corridor structures.
There's a few critical classes
we need to take a look at when defining a zone graph.
Firstly, we have the zone shape.
Zone shapes define the area and shape
of the zone graph lanes.
Zone shapes need to be configured
with a lane profile which determines
the number of lanes, tags, direction,
and width of the lane.
Next, we have the zone graph data.
The zone graph data is the built navigation data
for the zone graph,
and it's very similar to the Raycast actor
that is present when using nav mesh.
Zone graph data is not built automatically
whilst the user is editing.
It's instead built on demand
via the build zone graph tool from the menu bar.
However, we can enable automatic zone graph building
by enabling the build zone graph
whilst editing flag in the project settings.
Next, we have the zone graph testing actor,
which is used for testing if navigation is possible
between two testing actors,
similar to the traditional navigation testing actor
used with the Raycast nav mesh.
These testing actors can be configured with a query filter,
another actor to test the navigation between,
and optional tests to be run when attempting to navigate.
The testing actor can also show
other debug information related to pathfinding,
such as its path lane, its linked lanes,
smoothing, and the BV tree query.
Finally, we have the zone graph annotation testing actor.
This actor allows for any number of tests to be run
to simulate annotations at a specific point.
Custom tests can also be created
to match a project's specific needs.
Let's take a look at how we create a lane profile.
To create a lane profile, you simply do the following.
Go to project settings, zone graph,
and press the plus button to create a new lane profile.
In the example we see above,
we define a new profile that we've named two-way traffic.
We then add two lanes to this profile,
both with a width of 150,
and we define the direction of both of these lanes,
one being forwards and one being backwards.
And that concludes Introduction to AI in Unreal Engine 5.
Today we learned about AI controllers
and how to control them,
either through behavior trees or state trees,
as well as how to store information
for use in them on the blackboard.
We've looked at the navigation mesh
and how we can query information about the world with EQS.
We've learned what forms of Perception AI
can use straight out of the box.
We've also taken a look at some of the brand new features
in Unreal's toolset, the smart objects,
mass entity, and zone graph systems.
Thank you so much for watching, and have a fantastic day.